Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and a,
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast at [inaudible].
Ah,
um,
just checking in on you,
man.
How's your week going?
You know,
August 20th.
Holy Shit.
Where is this summer going?
Oh,
Billy fucking fat cakes.
pasty tits himself is still been staying on the Diet.
I weighed myself this morning down to a buck 68 and change my head,
his schedule,
supposed to be a buck 68 by Sunday.
But,
uh,
I actually,
I started eating a little more pro,
actually have increased the calories because I remember a long time ago that
dude who plays wolverine in the x men,
he was saying like towards the end when he wanted to get completely shredded,
like he was eating like a whole chicken every day.
So,
you know,
that was like probably 3.4 seconds worth of information.
So rather than going,
oh,
why don't I research that and see how to do it properly,
I just go,
oh,
okay,
okay guys playing Walter Reed and I,
I just fucking go with it.
So,
uh,
there was also some diet.
This,
uh,
this lady put me on like fucking 15 years ago and I vaguely remembered like at
four o'clock and six o'clock,
Yay to protein,
the size of the palm of your hand with the vegetable,
but both at four and it's six.
She kept your fruits before your fruit cakes there before 12.
I don't fucking,
all I know is it's been working for me.
He's been working for me.
So,
um,
I got this closet thing on the outside of the house.
I got this,
it,
uh,
they put a concrete floor and put some shelves up so I can get some of the shit
out of my fucking garage because I don't want to be that guy.
Don't be that guy with all this shit in his garage.
Right?
Like every time there's something,
where do we put that out?
Throw it in the garage,
throw it in the garage and next thing you know,
right.
You got it.
It's like,
looks like the beginning of Sanford and son.
It looks like they're fucking yard,
except they were selling the shit,
making money and I'm just,
I'm just stock piling it up.
So,
uh,
I got some shit.
I'm getting rid of some shit.
I'm getting given away.
And then I got like three boxes of DVDs just from years gone by.
I'm just gonna stop bringing those out to shows and was sound flag.
I Dunno what,
I'm a cell phone.
Just nothing.
Just to get rid of him,
get him out of my life and then I'll be good.
Then I'll have a nice open area.
You know,
I don't want,
I'm telling you guys this shit,
I'm fucking a,
I got this old bike that I bought my wife,
it's not even old.
It's nice.
She fucking used it like three times and she,
she fucked the whole thing up.
I don't know what she wrote it once and the gears never shifted.
Right again,
you know,
and I was just like,
what did you do to it?
She was like,
Tanya and that was it.
And then I've had to pay to get it fixed.
No rest of the time.
So anyways,
so I've telling Versie,
right?
I tell Versie that I'm bringing this bike over to get it fucking tuned up.
Then I'm going to sell it and then I'm going to buy a guy's bike.
And then he just starts laughing.
He goes,
I got to do a bit about that,
man.
He's just like,
you fucking guys who buy bikes.
He's like,
you're never going to use it.
You're never going to fucking use it.
And I'm just sitting there.
I'm like,
dude,
you're never going to use it.
You know what I mean?
It'd be like if you're not into cooking and somebody buys one of those fucking
things that smashes up the,
uh,
the garlic young,
you know,
a few fucking always order,
right?
You're like to why you buy it,
you're never going to use it.
It's like,
no,
dude,
you're never going to use it.
All right?
You're not the world.
But,
uh,
I don't know,
verse,
he was cracking me up today.
I was telling us that dude,
I'm down to a buck 60,
80,
cause your dad to a buck 68.
And I was like,
yeah.
He goes,
ah,
you know,
he goes,
I feel like you're like one of those still skinny Irish guys that can just
fucking eat anything,
you know?
I'm telling you right now,
that is the number one thing that people who are out of shape say,
not say versus out of shape,
but I've heard that for more Goddamn fatties in my lifetime.
They always want to say that you be you.
You know you could eat anything.
You know what you what your metabolism.
You can fucking eat anything.
Me,
you know I even look at Folk I put on weight.
Yeah,
you look at it and then you shove it down your fucking pie hall.
I love how fat and I don't want to go off on fat people,
but I'm of going to go off on him here.
I love how they try to act like we don't understand caloric intake.
Is that the right word?
I don't know.
It's like,
it's like,
dude,
I eat,
I eat food too.
I know what it does to me.
All right.
I just don't sit down with the whole fucking Bundt cake when I've had a bad day
and eat the whole fucking thing,
you know,
turning it upside down so the frosting touches my tongue rather than the roof of
my mouth so I can get more of a sugar fix,
you know?
See that I've,
I've dabbled,
I've met that my problems.
Um,
they're always saying that anytime to get in shape,
somebody always has to say like,
you know,
oh that's cause you in fucking a tab.
No,
it's cause I fucking,
I quit Bosun I hate fucking is perfect as I could.
And I worked out to the point,
my knees are fucking killing me.
That's how I got in shape.
I right there fucking uh oh,
whatever the fuck you written there with you.
If you're fucking blueberry muffins,
right.
Versus you sit there bitching and then halfway through and he tells me he
fucking eat a bag of gummy bears.
It's like,
what do you think your body does with that?
He's going like,
dude,
I can't fucking,
I can't get rid of my,
uh,
my stomach though.
My stomach.
That's the fucking thing.
I can't get rid of the stomach.
It's like,
well dude,
you put it on first there and then you take it on last.
So you,
you just got to,
you got to keep going.
As she fucking had them laughing.
I told him,
I said,
no Paul,
I go,
there's no difference between our metabolism.
All right,
I'm fucking 10 years older than you.
I'm 47 years old.
I don't want to hear that shit.
All right.
The simple fact is as I have more willpower than you and I'm,
I'm,
I'm way more red on nutrition and I don't know shit.
You know,
he actually laughed and I have to tell you right now,
I don't know shit about nutrition.
I don't,
I,
I listened to shit that people say and then I try it out and if it works then I
start doing it and then I repeat it to other people as if I did.
I guess I did do research cause I tried to use it.
I have no fucking idea,
but when it,
anyways,
all these fucking people,
fat people,
women are another group of people.
They'd say say stuff,
it's easier for a guy to Lewthwaite than it is for a woman.
You know?
It's like for example,
me and my boyfriend went on a diet the other day.
It's like two weeks later he's getting,
I barely lost any fucking wow.
Right.
They always say that shit.
You know,
it's cause I built from mothering where we fucking retained me to blah,
blah,
blah.
A excuses,
excuses,
eat a fucking salad and get on the treadmill like the rest of us.
You know,
I think the problem with what I think with women,
I just felt all female listeners just tuning out at this point is that they just
do a lot more social shit.
Yeah.
You know,
like a lot of this shit involves sitting around talking and in ordering
something.
You know what I mean?
Where guys,
it involves a lot of standing around while drinking,
you know?
And that's the difference right there.
You guys sit down and you consume your calories were standing up,
you know,
drinking a fucking Milla.
Um,
I dunno.
Maybe there's elements of truth,
I guess in some,
some people's metabolism is faster.
I imagine there's some element of truth of women having a little more difficult
time,
but I've never seen anybody that fucking worked out and ate right and did not
look good.
I can honestly tell you that there's,
I've never seen somebody go and like,
I'm eating Kale Salads and apples and for some reason I'm 350 pounds.
It's like,
well,
when you want to be honest about the other truck load of horse shit yet throwing
down your fucking throat when nobody's around,
you know,
I don't know what I'm saying.
I'm just saying I don't fucking buy into fat people,
women,
or just some pudgy guys.
Horseshit lie about your fucking metabolism.
You know what I mean?
Sitting around eating gummy bears and cakes.
You probably put your public,
they've put gummy bears on cakes,
don't they?
Big gummy bear cake.
And then you shove that down your fucking throat and then the next day you have
some oatmeal and,
and you think that that's going to give you abs.
I'm really being a fucking judgmental country,
Ernie.
Well,
that's what I do.
It is what I do when I'm on the fucking podcast.
Um,
so anyways,
I got,
oh,
uh,
what am I trying to say here?
I just realized I don't have my computer here and I don't have any of the
fucking subjects,
anything that I wanted to talk about.
Oh,
I'm going to be on Conan O'brien tonight and I actually planned on talking about
Tom Brady.
We just never to,
it fucking killed me.
I want to call Jim or a baby on that show and I think,
I can't believe I didn't.
But anyways,
that's going to be on tonight.
Uh,
it's a fucking monster shelf bonds to goddamn shelf.
go,
going to go on.
I have to fucking bill Hader.
And he went out destroying as always just one of those things where you sit in
there going like,
why am I going on it?
So this guy I should be going on for us.
But then how those shows work,
it's like he's got a movie coming out,
right?
Oh,
he's got that thing coming out with Fred Armisen.
Well they dress like Quakers.
I don't,
I don't know.
I didn't know what the fucking shows about.
All I know is I'm watching it because those two are hilarious.
But he was promoting that thing and I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
So let,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
hang on.
Hang on.
You know I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna go get my fucking computer cause I actually have to have the
advertising and all that and through the magic,
through the absolute fucking magic of me hitting the pause button.
I'll be back in half a second.
All right.
Just like dad,
I'm back and I get something to talk about.
Dude.
What the fuck happened to the guy who did the subway things?
Jared says he fides middle school girls hot.
Okay.
Some chick was taping them for fucking four years.
He's caused a lot of pain.
It's pain that will never go away.
What for saying that now he must have gone a little further than that on
Wednesday.
Follow admitted that he had sex with at least two minors and obtain child
profile,
not pornography of 12 other children as young as six years old.
A boy.
Dude,
is anything buddy safe?
Can anybody go wire to wire without the fucking hammer coming down?
Jared Fogle was a monster.
He's a monster.
That's what she said.
Okay.
How funny is it that I was just talking to you guys about eating right and
getting in shape and I go look at Google fucking news.
So I got some that run my Goddamn Yap about yes,
Jesus Christ.
And he looks like Derosa.
That's fucking hilarious.
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
Fogo served as subway spokesman for 15 years.
Ever since he first appeared on television claiming that eating the fast food
chains sandwiches and working out helped them lose more than 200 pounds.
Please.
He probably likes that money running out the back door when the parents came up.
See,
this is dumb.
I shouldn't be doing this.
This guy has not been convicted of anything.
Yeah.
Oh,
but he's completely fucked.
He better had done it.
I mean,
I hope he didn't for kids' sake,
but I mean,
he's fucked now it's over.
What's it?
You're going to go over the Blimpie?
Yeah.
Hey everybody.
I'm wrongly accused,
accused a child molester,
Jared Fogle and a,
I'm going to tell you that a Blimpie's makes you even more skinny.
Yeah.
And what the stress is sitting there,
uh,
you know,
thinking I was going to go to jail for that Shit and get gang raped.
Cause that's what happened.
God,
Jared,
what did you do?
Oh my God.
If he,
if he fucking did this shit and he's guilty,
he goes to jail.
Do you have any fucking idea what's going?
I love that they put them in protective custody for how fucking long,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
Figure maybe eight,
10 years.
He's fucked.
Literally.
Oh my God.
They'll descend on a May.
Jerry,
what do you want the six of the 12 inch?
God,
I fucking kill myself.
Oh,
there's gotta be a way to do it is to fucking skinny now to hang himself.
Just sit there and twitching around like a fucking God damn fly.
They've got its wings ripped off.
How do you kill yourself when you're shaped like a pencil?
Oh God.
What do you do?
Oh,
I know.
I do.
I fucking break my glasses and I jam.
One of the pieces in my neck just bleed out in the cell.
There you go.
Let's see.
There's always a way.
You know that you put somebody in a confined area there.
They're going to come up with something.
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
I don't understand why before the guy's convicted that his face is all over the
fucking place.
I don't get it because if this guy didn't do this shit,
it was like,
what the fuck I was talking about last week about the hockey player there.
It's like if they didn't do it,
they completely fucked fucked.
Either way.
Either they did it and they go into jail and getting gang raped.
You know what's,
you know let's what you get for doing that shit.
But on the other side,
if you did do whatever,
you know,
what do,
what are you,
how do you make your money then?
I Dunno.
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
Wow.
Okay.
Jeb Bush.
Donald Trump,
unapologetic for anchor baby language.
I gotta I gotta be honest with you as far as like,
you know,
offensive shit.
Anchor baby.
That's good.
That's pretty fucking light.
You know what I mean?
There's no racial epitaphs and there is nothing homophobic anchor baby.
It's the baby that gets you in here.
You don't,
you put down roots.
Right?
How about a root baby?
[inaudible] baby,
I
hate that fucking report to you.
Generally.
Would you fish?
Shut the fuck up.
You're offensive.
You fucking cunt.
You work for some corporate Goddamn News News.
Fucking paper.
Quit acting like you're giving out the facts.
You jerk off.
You write about what they tell you to write about.
That's what you should have done.
You write what they tell you to write about.
Then you go on your cash,
those checks don't Ya.
And you got to go buy yourself an Audi,
right?
Or a BMW,
some German sedan that lets the bras.
No,
you're fucking,
you know,
you're on the Dole.
Um,
you gotta be fucking kidding me,
man.
Jesus Christ.
If you can't trust a form of fuck fat who's eaten sandwiches to be around your
kids,
honestly,
who can you trust?
That would been a great fucking segue to go into my advertising.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh,
it's here.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Everything's just falling apart on me here.
All right.
It's time for some advertising.
I mean,
what else?
What else do you do after you talk about the form of fat?
Fuck.
Who became a skinny guy and then uh,
allegedly
Jesus Christ.
I get,
wow.
Anyways,
I don't fuck you think you're going to get away with something like that?
Um,
all right.
Okay.
Be One thing.
If you were the spokesperson for Wendy's,
like that old guy,
then he could just say,
Nah,
no,
I was just dressed as Santa.
All right.
It's okay.
Let's,
what do we got here?
What am I reading here?
Is it Oxford?
Yeah.
Oh,
blue apron.
It's okay.
You can admit the last thing anyone wants to do after work is wait in line at
the grocery store,
Schlep home and cook a complicated meal and expensive,
unhealthy takeout is hardly any,
right?
That's where the new service blue apron comes in.
Why is the apron blue?
I don't know.
Blue Apron delivers farm fresh ingredients and step by step recipes to your
home,
allowing you to create healthy handcrafted meals at home without going to the
grocery store for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron sends you a sense you fresh ingredients,
perfectly proportioned,
making,
cooking healthy meals,
really easy and fun.
Oh boy.
Meatloaf,
no trips to the grocery store and no waste from unused ingredients.
Plus you'll learn to cook was special.
Specialty ingredients that are normally hard to find.
Blue Apron is perfect for date night cooking with friends that's fucking hold
perfect for date night until she finds out
okay.
It's going to become a slang suit and then this motherfucker blue apron make try
to act like he made that shit.
Sell crack.
Crackup please.
Blue Apron is perfect for date night cooking with friends and they even offer
family plans with kid friendly ingredients so the whole family can eat well and
have fun preparing the meals together.
What is kid friendly meat?
The fuck would we a kid friendly ingredients.
Sugar.
Each balanced meal is 500 to 700 calories per serving and so tasty.
You'd never know.
Cooking takes half an hour.
Shipping is flexible and free,
and the menus are always knew they won't send you the same meal twice.
They work around your schedule and dietary preferences.
They do everything but chew it for you and shove it your mouth and blue aprons
experts source out only the best seasonal ingredients for incredible meals like
Parmesan crusted chicken with roasted heirloom potatoes and tomatoes.
Arugula Salad,
Tandoori spice,
chicken with green lentils,
eggplant and Cucumber Mint Yogurt.
How many meals was that?
Was that one?
Yeah.
Let's see.
You got your chicken with potatoes and you have a salad and he got them.
Oh,
and they got more chicken.
That's gotta be the different one.
That one you have with lentils,
Eggplant,
cucumber,
Mint Yogurt.
Anyways,
you'll cook incredible meals and be blown away by the quality and the freshmen
blue apron.
It's a better way to cook.
Check out this week's menu and get your first two meals for free by going to
blue apron.com/burr my treat.
Really the first two meals or rotten me.
When you go to blue apron,
blue apron.com/burr hey,
blue apron.com/ [inaudible] all right,
what else do we got here?
Okay,
important.
Now please do not leave out the mandatory I italicize verbiage.
Verbiage.
All right?
Okay.
I can't fucking read this.
Alright.
Do you want the government?
Oh,
this is legal zone.
Do you want the government to decide what happens to your property and minor
children?
If not,
make the commitment to protect your family with the last will or living trust
today.
It's national.
Make a will month once again and legal zoom.com at legalzoom.com and doing the
right thing has never been easier.
They've created a better way for you and your spouse to take control of your
family's future.
Checkout legal zooms,
new last will and living trust bundles.
The more you plan ahead with wills,
trusts,
and powers of attorney,
the more you save.
Even if you're confused about all the options.
Don't let that hold you back.
Plow right in.
You can use,
they're easy online resources and estate planning tool to help you figure out
what you need or get more specific guidance from legalzoom's network of
independent attorneys in most states since they're not a law firm,
don't procrastinate when it comes to protecting your family.
Get a legal help you can count on@legalzoom.com today.
Don't forget to enter in bar in the referral box at checkout to save even more.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code burr legal zoom.com promo bar,
Promo code bar.
Right?
I don't know what the fuck I just said and last but not least,
hey,
you like making great money,
right?
I feel like I should.
We stand in an alley right now with him wearing a raincoat.
Here's a really cool opportunity I had to share with you hanging out with Jared.
No,
sorry.
Driving with Uber.
Uber does that Popular Smart Phone App that connects riders with drivers.
Um,
people take Uber a bunch and they love them by the way,
and they loved chatting up with the different drivers.
Some of them have really interesting stories as to why they drive with Uber.
They love being their own boss.
They may are great money.
It's easy to start.
You just need a car and a license.
Driving with Uber is great for anyone who needs flexibility.
Parents,
this is a really easy way to work around your family schedules.
Storage.
You can make more extra money between classes,
serial killers,
kidding.
Uh,
now's the prime time to cash and driving with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling how to get paid every week.
I could be getting into your car when you drive with Uber.
I won't be sober.
A call to action.
You got a car and the license.
Put a boat together,
make it more for you and you start earning some serious life changing money
today.
Sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com.
That's drive with uber.com.
Drive with uber.com.
Yeah,
we go mercifully.
The advertising has done for this week.
No more me reading out loud.
Um,
let's get back.
Let's talk about the fucking baseball here is I get interested as the dog days
of summer wind down.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
it's fucked up.
The fucking red sox.
We were even worse.
I can't get fucking Internet in here.
We say no.
Who's in first place now,
right?
American league ace is the Yag gauge.
Um,
I got some new kid.
I saw you had a couple of home runs.
He of the night something bird.
Uh,
Kansas City's in first place.
Yeah,
the American league central and then in the west.
I don't know who it is.
And the Dodgers are in first place.
The mets are in first place and the cardinals,
I just don't know who's in first place.
Okay.
Fuck.
Would it be the angels?
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
I'm psyched.
The Dodgers are in.
Maybe I'll go to a playoff game.
Oh,
really?
Bill for we,
you think this sitting around waiting for you.
You can't.
Um,
anyways,
hey,
is this,
is this a bad thing?
I got all this extra shit in my garage.
Like,
I have like half cans a Turpentine and all this crap leftover from when they
were redoing the bottom of the,
of my piece of shit.
Fucking tree fort of a house,
uh,
which is now much nicer.
Okay.
Much nicer.
But now we're doing the upstairs because uh,
you know,
all the wiring was put in by Herman Munster in the fucking Jesus Christ.
And I want to get into it.
I have fucking holes in my walls again because,
uh,
you know,
all they have to say is,
I don't know.
Pipe looks a little old.
And after this shit I went through,
I'm just like,
oh,
whoa,
whoa.
It's sex.
All of it.
And that's what they've been doing.
So I have pretty much,
I have copper pipes going through almost all of the house and now they're
talking about the sink.
Well,
you know,
we could go through a wall and the catch it at this fucking,
is that what you could do?
Is that what you get though?
Just fucking do it.
Cut The fucking thing open and get it done with.
I feel like I've been having open heart surgery on this Goddamn fucking house.
Ah,
what a dope.
What kind of a fucking dope buys a fucking house.
That's 90 years old and is in a state in the middle of a drought.
Good move bill.
Wait at golf.
Did you read the art of the deal?
Got To love Trump.
You said the greatest fucking,
you said the second grade book of all time is his book,
the art of the deal.
And then the right behind the Bible,
the guy,
he's crushing it as far as the one liners,
he's a quote machine.
He's like rex.
Rex Ryan ran for president that actually had money.
You know.
Oh,
by the way,
I saw this thing on real sports.
It was really passive aggressive by that fucking tool shed.
Bryant Bryant Gumbel,
I'm gonna sit Bryant gumball.
Um,
you know the fucking,
they come back to him,
right?
And he's got his little clipboard of questions and he's like,
Oh,
you know,
he's always fucking,
whenever you got the question,
his voice goes really high.
Ooh.
And,
um,
he fucking,
uh,
they were doing a story on Rex Ryan and he,
this is what he said.
He said,
most coaches are stoic,
like Tom Kauflin or socially inept control freaks like bill Belicheck,
you know,
but not outspoken,
Brash Rex Ryan that was so fucking passive aggressive.
What,
that everybody in the media hates bill Belicheck because he won't talk to him.
You talked to the Patriots.
They say he's fucking hilarious and he has a great personality.
That shit that he does is no different than what shack did.
Shack in the beginning of his career would fuck around.
And then he realized what Consta fucking media was.
And it's all right.
I'm not giving you anything because it just motivates the other team.
That's what Bella check does.
That's why Gig Shack,
if you see him do an MTV cribs,
he's got this amazing personality.
You watch him do the fucking commentating in between the fucking the haves.
He's fucking hilarious.
Totally outgoing.
If you watch him during his career,
he's just like,
where are we going to ball Colby?
Colby?
Good me.
Uh,
through row,
he'll do the layup,
try to scroll of bullet points of him.
That's all one want good.
Still lead with three more.
That's all he would do.
All he was doing,
you get them on MTV cribs.
He's a fucking riot.
Thrown his kids around on his giant bed.
Right?
That's the same thing with Bellacheck.
Bellicheck just goes out there,
you know,
hey,
you play in this piece of shit team next week and that's going to be an easy
win,
right?
And not going to be easy.
And he just goes,
wow.
You know,
say,
yeah,
see NFL,
every team has a worthy opponent and we're not looking past them himself.
All we're focused on right now is trying to beat the Jacksonville Jaguars.
And then they get mad because it's just like,
I,
you didn't say something crazy,
you know,
this sniffing feet.
You know what I mean?
You're not predicting that you're going to win the fucking super bowl.
And they actually,
this is what kills me.
So they fucking,
they say that he's socially inept and a control freak and then they say,
Rex Ryan is super confident.
And then they're talking about when he was the kid,
how he was unbelievably insecure and kids picked on him and all that.
And it's showing pictures of him when he's like a,
like 11 to 12 it's like,
that shit doesn't go away.
You're still that guy.
You're just that guy and you weigh 200 more pounds.
That's all.
But having said all that,
I'm psyched.
He fucking lost the weight.
You know,
he looks great and I think he's going to do real well out in buffalo with that
defense sets the exact fucking team that he should be coaching.
He did great with the jets when the jets had a defense and I think that's a
fucking home run.
But he's got the same problem,
I think maybe not as bad that he had in New York,
which he has nobody at the quarterback position.
So call me crazy,
but I just say it's going to be more the same.
I think he's going to talk shit.
He's going to say that they're going to win the,
you already said that they're gonna make the playoffs.
I think they're going to do well.
And then some guys are going to want to get more money and when their contract
gets up,
they want to fucking play in a warmer place with more media attention and then
they're going to leave and he's going to be left with no fucking quarterback.
Had No defense.
And that's how that's going to go.
You know,
who knows?
I'm not saying he's a bad coach,
I'm just predicting he's going to get fired.
What I kind of,
um,
either way I'm looking forward to it.
Um,
can't wait for football season.
CanNot fucking wait.
So is the deal.
I,
um,
we're going to be going to that Texas Longhorn,
a Oklahoma state,
uh,
football games.
We do that run through Texas.
And then,
um,
I got another run towards the end of October where I'm going through the Midwest
and now trying to find games.
Weekend,
I'm in Chicago.
Northwestern has a road game.
Illinois has a fucking road game.
Then I looked,
I fucking,
Purdue was home.
Iowa was home,
but then I was like,
come on man,
there's gotta be,
there's gotta be a fucking game close by.
And then I looked like three days before the tour starts.
Notre Dame play in USC at Notre Dame.
So,
uh,
I might be adding a couple extra standup dates and maybe going to try to go to
that model.
We'll see.
That's an outside chance.
But if I'm not,
I think I'm going to go to that Purdue game after I do the Chicago theater.
We're going to go drive over there playing Nebraska.
Uh,
I've always liked Purdue in Nebraska was a fucking power house when I was a kid.
Um,
Irving Fryer,
Mike Rozier,
Turner Gill,
I almost said Jimmy Johnson coached him,
but each coast ti coach that Miami team that beat Nebraska and that amazing
championship game,
I believe the fuck was it coach.
I can't remember.
But they just had,
they just had one hall of fame,
offensive Lineman after another when I was coming up and they used to just be
like,
I remember when you get those,
those football cards that were just for skill,
just like a,
that fucking a draft kings,
right.
Just for skill.
And that was back when you could actually bet on Games,
um,
where the spread was like 70 points.
So you'd be sitting there and every week,
like you just,
you just bet against Nebraska,
you had to,
you were getting like 65,
70 points and we'd all be at school laughing,
just going,
how do you lay off this game?
It's like you're up 70 to nothing already.
Um,
you know,
and use banking on the fact that they'll score 50 early and then put their
scrubs in and not going to,
it's not going to happen.
And these fucking assholes,
Nebraska,
they used to cover,
they used to cover and we hated losing money,
but we just thought it was the funniest fucking thing ever.
You know,
losing money sucks,
but losing money that way,
that's just something hilarious about it.
Um,
and then you'd end up losing your bed and then just rooting for them to go for
two points and try to somehow score a hundred.
But,
uh,
but anyways,
so we're going to be going to that game,
possibly the,
the,
uh,
the Notre Dame game.
And I might even in November,
I got another road gig that they,
and there's a chance,
mmm.
Oh miss and Lsu a play.
And I might be able to,
that'd be three in one year.
That'd be fucking sick.
So that's what I'm working towards.
That's what I'm working towards,
if you can believe it.
Um,
anyways,
so how,
I feel like there was something else I want to tell you.
I'm going to be on Conan.
MMM.
I think that's it.
I'm going to be uncommon and that's it.
I'm calling it tonight.
Check it out.
It's a,
what am I trying to say here?
Oh,
so tonight,
uh,
the guests are bill Hader then myself and this hilarious comic sans moral and
everybody,
you know,
it's actually a fucking great show to be honest with you.
So tune in if he can,
you know,
try to watch it live.
Sit through the commercials,
you know,
I know nobody does anymore,
but anyways,
that's the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Uh,
have a great weekend,
your cuts and uh,
talk to you on Monday.
Okay.
Uh,
all right.
I know this girl,
I've known her for a bit.
Uh,
we're friends.
We've been for awhile.
Okay.
Now this one,
you know how everybody always trashes me for the way I fucking read.
I know I suck at reading,
but I have to let you know.
This is all in lowercase and there's absolutely no punctuation whatsoever.
I don't know if this guy text message this or what,
but this is not my fucking fault.
Let me try my best to read this.
All right,
Bill.
I know this girl.
I've known her for a bit and we're friends.
No period.
We've been for a while,
comma.
Anyway,
about a month ago,
I asked her out on a date and she said yes,
comma,
continuing the sentence.
He doesn't have periods.
He just has calm is lowercase.
I took her out and we had fun.
No period.
We talked.
Shit
was Hunky Dory.
No Comma,
we kissed it.
No period.
It was awesome.
First date,
it was an awesome first date.
Hey,
there's a period,
no capital letter.
Then I,
I barely fucking heard from her.
No.
Period.
I was running around like a fucking jackass.
No period.
Just trying to talk to her and I'm sorry.
I guess it keeps going.
Just trying to talk to her and when we would talk it was fine.
Now there's a period I was beating myself up going crazy.
No,
period.
I was some piece of shit.
Anyway,
I pulled myself together and I asked her out again.
She wants against said yes.
Awesome.
Right.
Well not your fucking lack of punctuation.
That's not awesome.
So we go out again when cool.
Again,
I didn't kiss her this time.
I don't know.
It was just off.
But anyway,
comma,
that was no punctuation and all of that.
You fucking Dick.
Once again,
I was fucking,
once again,
I fucking didn't hear a thing,
so I said,
fuck it.
I don't need this right now.
And we just went back to being friends,
never talked about it.
Just let it lay.
Fucking see double at this point.
Anyway,
lately I've been talking to her a lot.
Like I said,
like I said,
we're friends,
but she's very clearly been flirting with me and I honestly have been flirting
back.
I still like the girl,
no period,
no nothing,
but I just don't know if it's worth it.
You know,
period.
No question mark.
She's got a lot of drama.
She's one of these girls that gets drunk at a party and cries.
Then ask people if she's pretty,
which she really fucking is like really hot dot,
dot,
dot.
Ah,
but I do like her,
I just don't know if I should put myself through this shit again.
What do you think bill?
I legitimate legitimately,
we'd like your advice slash opinion.
Um,
okay.
The first thing I would do,
I would get some sort of spell check.
I would get some sort of,
uh,
um,
phonics or some sort of shit to teach you how to write.
All right?
People I know I suck at reading out loud,
but can,
can you do me a fucking solid?
I'm not reading any more fucking emails that are like this.
All right?
Cause I,
this is literally,
if I'm,
I'm starting to lose my fucking eyesight.
Um,
so what do I think?
Yeah.
Okay.
This is what I think.
I think you should definitely not get into a relationship with this girl,
this girl that this girl is a fucking nightmare.
All right?
There's all kinds of red flags.
I don't know what happened to her and I can tell you right now,
you don't want to find out what's happening to her,
what happened to her.
You don't want to find out in that you don't want to have feelings for this
girl.
All right?
And when the other fucking bag of shit hits the floor and your heart is
underneath that,
you don't.
You don't.
You don't let it grow like this.
Break your heart.
All right?
You can see it from a mile away.
She is a fucking mess.
Yeah.
All right.
There's plenty of great girls out there.
You're a young guy.
Go find one.
All right.
Find a girl,
you know,
make a list of shit.
All right?
One of the big things,
if you want to find a really good girl is find one who has a great relationship
with her parents.
Hopefully they're still together.
All right?
That's another good thing.
Start with that,
but does this,
and then
they got low self esteem issues.
You're going to kill a decade,
a your fucking life trying to build them up and you know what it's going to be,
it's going to be fucking exhausting.
All right?
And then,
because she doesn't think she's pretty,
she might act out sexually,
um,
for some sort of,
you know,
I don't know,
like,
Geez,
I just really,
I'm an hour and six minutes in here,
just,
you know,
some sort of affirmation that she is pretty okay.
So what do I think you should do?
All right,
well,
if you're a well adjusted guy,
you'll just walk away from the situation and say that I'm not going to just bang
her and use that as a fucking Nacho.
My bedpost to make my ego feel good and I'm not going to hurt this person.
But if you're,
how most people are your age,
I would just say bang her and then,
uh,
I dunno,
it's,
it's going to be ugly.
If you want to bang this girl,
I got to tell you,
don't let your heart get involved at,
uh,
I dunno.
Not,
not having seen her,
not seeing how she is and being older and more mature,
I would say just walk away and go find some,
well adjusted hottie that's,
unless you just want a bank.
So buddy,
but then you,
you can do that.
You know what it is about this thing?
You know what?
I don't like this too much fucking history.
You got to be able to leave.
You gotta be able to fucking go out the side door.
If you just going to bank somebody,
you can't have this.
Well,
we were friends at first and then it became romantic.
Then we went back to being friends and then we fucked.
And it's just a fucking nightmare.
Yeah,
I'd find someone else to fuck.
But if you don't give a shit,
yeah,
I banger.
But by no means don't develop any sort of feelings for her.
Alright,
there you go.
That's my advice.
Yay.
Got Your Bill.
Recently I had to return some items at the mall.
Uh,
it was the day after Christmas and I was with a girl.
I was dating,
uh,
with the girl that I was dating.
She wanted to return some shoes.
So we went to the journey store with his shoes were,
but uh,
when she got to the counter to return the shoes,
the girl behind the counter asked her for her name,
address,
email,
and phone number.
Oh my God.
The amount of fucking people who actually give out that information.
My girlfriend just gave the information over.
As soon as the girl asked for it,
we were leaving the store.
I remarked that I thought it was bullshit that she had to give away personal
information to return a pair of shoes.
She said,
uh,
it was not a big deal,
but I didn't like it.
All right.
Why the fuck would you give somebody all in information and just in case you're
new to my podcast,
just say you can say no.
Okay.
Can I,
you know,
I,
I go out to buy shit all the time.
Could I have your phone number?
No.
Yeah.
I don't even say,
I don't even try and make it nice.
I just say no and then they go,
oh,
okay.
You know,
why do you feel like you got to give them their information?
You're trying to buy something.
I'm sorry I can't,
I can't show you this unless I get your information.
Well they go fuck yourself applied somewhere else.
I don't even need it anyways.
So anyways,
he goes,
next,
we go to American Eagle.
You guys hit all the hot spot,
Huh?
Then we went to Cinnabon.
Next we went to American Eagle where I had to return a shirt.
That was a gift.
It was a long line for returns.
Why'd you return the shirt and did it not fit or was it ugly as hell or was it
both?
As I was waiting in line,
one of the employees comes up to me with a clipboard with the little form to
fill out now.
Is anybody else kind of getting the prison camp vibe here?
You know,
they're standing in line to get processed and there's a guy coming up onto the
VAT.
Is Your name please?
Your phone number?
Uh,
I stopped the employee.
I stopped the employee and asked her why she needed this information and she
says that it was to verify my purchase.
How fucking dumb our people.
You're going to verify my purchase.
Well,
here's the sales slips there,
sweetheart.
This verifies it.
That's it.
I don't know what to tell you.
Why don't you and your clipboard?
Why don't you hold that clipboard between your little fucking beef curtains and
take a fucking walk down the street?
How about that?
How sweetheart there,
there's the reasons you use that type of language.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Huh?
How about I fucking grabbed that pony tail and just,
no,
let's,
let's keep it clean this week,
shall we?
People anyway,
she,
he goes before I could protest further,
she said that I could just put name on it.
Okay.
Oh,
on the clipboard.
Okay.
When she walked away,
I pulled out the gift receipt has said to my girlfriend,
oh,
here it is.
You have,
this is what verifies my purchase.
Exactly.
The clipboard employee wasn't as far as way as I thought she was and heard me
say,
did I read that wrong?
Get heard me say it's heard me say this.
And she began to explain further why I needed to give over the information.
This is the part of the email I hate.
He goes,
I apologized and told her.
I realized it wasn't her and that it was just her company's policy that she was
enforcing.
She walked away again.
I felt bad.
So the next time I saw her I apologized and said,
I realized that she was just doing her job,
but she ignored me.
She was probably pissed because it was the day after Christmas and I was causing
your grief,
but you could at least accept my apology.
You Bitch.
Um,
I love how you go from being totally liberal and seeing somebody fucking side of
it too,
being yeah,
man up,
you can't.
Um,
anyway,
I got up to the counter and there wasn't any further problems.
The guy at the register just took my name and didn't ask me for anything.
I felt as though I had a small victory against the big corporations.
Then this week I had to go back to the store to return a hat my girlfriend got.
Did you guys not make Christmas lists or all your relatives blind?
The seems to be a lot of,
uh,
returning of gifts.
Yeah.
This is hilarious.
You're returning a hat that your girlfriend got you dude.
How horrific was that hat?
Can you please send me a picture of it before I,
if you took one before you returned it?
Picture one of those,
uh,
plaid Charlie Chaplin Hat.
Um,
I had the receipt,
but again,
the girl at the register asked me for my address and phone number.
I said I didn't want to give that information to her immediately panic sets in
and her face and she says that I have to,
I said that I didn't have to the day after Christmas and I wasn't going to now,
good for you.
She calls over a coworker and they both get defensive and hold to the idea that
I have to give over my information in order to return a stupid hat.
Even though I had my receipt,
I asked why and they let me slide.
Why the let me slide on this before and they maintained that I had,
I had to give them my name,
address and phone number.
So what did I do in the face of corporate opposition?
I caved and I gave it to him.
You Fuck?
Yeah,
Dude.
The second you saw the panic on their face,
you knew that they were going to lose.
All right.
He goes,
I just don't get it,
Bill.
Why is a receipt not enough?
Nowadays it is enough.
They say they need our personal information to verify purchase then not,
dude,
they're not.
All right.
All of that shit.
All those little save,
you know,
you want to get one our discount store,
they're creating a file on you.
They figure out what you want to buy,
what they can market towards you,
and then take that information and they sell it to other fucking companies.
Even though they say they're not going to,
they sell your information,
your information gets up on the Internet.
And that's why there's all these creepy websites out there right now that have
all this fucking information about you,
about,
you know,
how many siblings you have,
your brothers and sisters names,
they all use that information to fucking,
it's,
I'm telling you,
okay,
this don't give them your information.
You don't have to give him your information and people out there
who just have this fucking attitude towards these corporations just sitting
there going like,
wait,
you know what we do?
What are they going to be?
As long as you're not doing anything wrong.
I mean,
what do I care if they know where I live?
What do I keep this fucking morons?
I don't even,
I have explained this shit till I'm blue in the face and then I always get these
emails from these people.
Um,
they just,
I don't know.
I can't,
if I said something the other day I was sitting there listening.
I was sitting there,
I was listening to us sports radio,
you know,
cause I'm a deep thinker.
All right.
And uh,
this,
this new guy got on sports radio out here in Los Angeles and you know,
he does what most people do when they have nothing to say,
which is they,
they just start,
they just go over the top arrogant,
you know what I mean?
Like he was talking about how he wanted to get some,
some sort of sports culture personality on the show,
but he doubted he could get him as a guest because the guest hated him.
And he goes,
you know,
cause I disagreed with them on some,
he was talking to a coach and he was actually disagreeing with the,
with the fucking coach.
He's disagreeing with the guy and he goes,
you know what the problem is,
you know,
he goes like,
I'm just like such a good debater.
I actually ended up like convincing myself of my own opinion.
You actually said that over the airwaves and I just sorta muttered to myself
that the confidence of morons is staggering.
You know what I mean?
Morons think they know everything.
That's,
that's what makes them fucking morons.
And like the emails,
like get with people who don't question the shit.
Um,
which is,
I dunno,
like last week when I,
when I went off on my little fucking rant there,
just some of the fucking emails I get,
it's like people are sending me Shit.
That kinda is backing up what I'm saying.
And then telling me that it sounded like I have tin foil on my fucking head,
which obviously I am out of my fucking mind on some level,
but I'm not out of my mind when I don't trust corporations and I don't trust
them when they say we're not gonna do anything with this information.
The other day I was in cvs and I go to buy something and the lady asked me,
did I have a safe card?
And I said,
no.
She said,
do you want one?
And I said,
no.
And she goes,
well,
that's okay.
I'll just,
and she swiped the fucking thing anyways.
And I was like,
lady,
what did I just say to you now?
See if I use my credit card,
they'd have my name
and then to match up to that fucking number and what the hell I just bought and
just a little bit more information about me and my question to all you people
who have these,
this faith,
okay
in these corporations,
why does that person do that?
Why are they so hell bent on trying to make that corporation less money in that
moment?
They give me this card,
you know like everybody has those cards so you're not saving any fucking money.
It's just,
it's a big fucking shell game to make it seem,
oh look,
you saving money.
What they're really doing there,
they look at this hand over here is you're giving them all your personal fucking
information that they can then use to the very least sell to other corporations
to increase junk mail and it also to a limit you're fucking level of privacy.
The fact that they can put all that shit up in the Goddamn Internet.
People have been sending me these random websites where they have like your name
and your address,
where you fucking live and all this type of shit.
It's like,
how do you think that they get all that information?
Do you think there's somebody sitting there with the phone book and just typing
all of this shit in?
I don't know.
I'll fuck it up.
Okay.
If someone was,
what's what kills me?
If some fucking random creepy guy,
you know you're standing there waiting for the subway,
came up to you,
asks you what's your name,
your phone number and your address was,
would you give it to him?
No,
but for some reason you're inside of a fucking store and there's socks and
sweaters and somebody has a name tag.
Now all of a sudden you,
you,
you give them total fucking trust.
You're writing your mind.
So sir,
don't cave in.
All right.
All you get,
you just,
just say,
that's unacceptable.
That's unacceptable.
I want to speak to the manager what they're doing.
It's not legal yet.
It's not legal yet,
but I can guarantee you there's somebody lobbying for it that in Washington
there's some sort of fucking high powered lobbying group.
I swear to God is probably lobbying that from here on out,
we need to have a law that if you're going to return a hat,
you have to give us your name,
your address,
and your social security number just so there's not another nine 11 could guaran
fucking tee it.
So yeah,
you don't have to.
That's actually one of the highlights of my day.
What I do now is when they say,
do you have our little savings save card?
And I say,
no I don't.
Would you like one?
No,
I don't.
I then say,
and please don't swipe another one.
You know,
and then I try to pay with cash.
I love cash.
Cash is fucking anonymous.
All you guys out there who was sitting there watching these commercials where
they make it look like credit cards is so fucking easy.
You're idiots if you have,
you're buying into exactly what they want you to buy into,
which is a cashless society so they can keep track of where you are at all
fucking times and every last fucking dime that you make so they can get their
greedy little fucking hands on it.
You're out of your mind and you're giving up an unbelievable amount of fucking
privacy by creating a paper trail.
Everywhere you go,
everywhere you go,
what you're doing,
where you're at,
you know,
and the Sea of morons who we're going to sit there and go,
whoa,
VA doing anything wrong.
I mean,
I guess maybe,
maybe I'm a paranoid psycho.
You look at all these fucking idiots who do reality TV's and it,
and they elect cameras come into their house and they don't seem to care about
it.
Maybe,
uh,
maybe the average jackass doesn't give a shit.
But sir,
for the love of God,
you know,
in the end he says,
I'm not crying conspiracy.
It's very plain to see what they're doing.
It's not malicious or evil.
Yes it is.
It is malicious and it is evil and it is a conspiracy.
They're conspiring to get everybody's information,
find out what they buy,
and they're lying to you saying that they're not going to share the information.
It's everything that you're saying.
It's not.
It is.
All right.
And that's it.
That's two weeks in a row.
I'm on the soapbox.
See people,
don't you like it better when I talk about sports?
Ooh,
right.
Hyssop hyssop conspiracy theory for you.
Somebody said bill that they uh,
he wrote,
they are watching and um,
I got trashed for talking about conspiracy theory.
I've been trashed for talking about those automated checkout lines in the
grocery store and saying that I'm paranoid and I'm afraid of technology and all
this technology's just going to help my life and make my life more easier.
And why don't you trust these big fucking corporations?
Basically it's the shift that people will get from me.
So I have to get trashed.
Ralph,
you know,
talking shit about all these quirks.
Actually
having the audacity to think that bankers,
we're all trying to team up and have one World Bank had help to become the loan
sharks for not have not only individual but actual countries.
Okay.
Which is something that I was thinking about when I was at the Rose Bowl stone
sober and I was sitting there on the golf course and I was looking at these
houses up on up on the ridge of this hill that actually looked down on,
on the Roosevelt,
the granddaddy of them.
All these people have a house that looks down on it.
And I was actually envisioning that those were all bankers up there.
And while the game was going on in 104,000 people or 96,000 we ever showed up
for that game,
was sitting there going fucking crazy.
One of those pieces of Shit bankers up there could put his hand on his son's
shoulder and be like,
see all those people down there,
they owe all of us money.
They all owe me money,
son.
I'm getting a piece of all of their fucking paychecks and they don't even know
it.
They don't even know that their daddy is looking down on him right now.
Now had it been drinking,
that thought would have probably caused me to,
uh,
you know,
entertain the thought of climbing up that hill and throwing a rock through one
of the windows,
which of course I wouldn't have done because even my drunkest I am,
I am aware that I don't want to go to jail and get raped.
And secondly,
I really,
I'm not going to go all the way up.
That fucking helps.
What I've done is I probably would have yelled at that kid with the light purple
slacks.
I would've commented really loud about that dude's fucking,
uh,
Eczema flaking off into the back of his goddamn sweatshirt.
Um,
so anyways,
this guy sends me this email and he says,
build the vase in this blog.
When I say they are watching our big business,
not the Illuminati,
but they are just as evil as any bank or secret society.
They don't even need your signature.
Listen to this shit.
They don't even need your signature for these information gathering trader where
programs to monitor everything from where the device is to what your heart rate
is.
What is trade where?
That's the question I had.
Um,
you digital camera may embed metadata into photographs with cameras,
serial number or your location.
Your printer may be incorporating a secret code on every page at prince,
which could be used to identify the printer and potentially the person who used
it.
Now,
now the fucking morons,
the sheep out there and be like,
yeah,
that's in case she threatened the president did just doing it for the good of
all people.
Um,
if apple puts a particularly creepy patent,
I guess Apple's applying for this as a recently applied for the use,
um,
for,
you can look forward to a day when your iPhone may record your voice.
Take a picture of your location,
record your heartbeat,
and send that information back to the mothership.
Yeah,
this is Trey to wear devices that act behind your back and portray,
portray your privacy.
Now,
this is what the moron sheep are going to be to say,
well,
if
do nothing row,
which the prowl.
Okay,
that's,
that's the philosophy.
That was the philosophy behind why they can record your phone calls.
Now,
if you ain't doing nothing,
we're tasting,
come out frogs gay doing nothing wrong.
Do you realize how fucking dumb that mindset is?
So basically as long as you do what the people in power tell you what to do,
you won't have a problem.
Do you understand how dangerous that is?
Do you want to stay and how fucking stupid it is to have that level of faith in
the people who rule you?
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Hey,
you haven't noticed
how much power can fuck somebody over.
Like for some reason we always seem to focus on when celebrities get famous and
then they wig out and start becoming these fucking mini tyrants.
For some reason people don't feel they just have like this because they waved
the flag and they and they play those songs that make you choked up that they
never feel like that they'll have any sort of ulterior motive.
For this.
This is the type
of technology that allows a small group of people to take over the world.
Something that's socio paths have been trying to do since the beginning of time,
and they were never able to do it because at some point your army would be
stretched too thin.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Germans,
the fucking Roman empire,
all that shit.
At some point,
the fucking Japanese,
all of them,
everybody who's ever tried to fucking do it,
at some point it gets stretched too thin.
So America,
what we've done
is we then,
we,
we've,
we've done the,
we're putting this base here to protect you thing,
that brilliant thing.
That's how we got our world empire.
So we just have a base.
Then also we have these insane weapons where we can nuke everybody.
So we were able to kind of do it that way.
But the problem is,
is when you really get into sociopathic thought,
and just like those people who are so into power that it makes it dick hard is
they want to know.
They want to be able to see everybody,
know what they're thinking and know what they're doing at all times because not
only they psychos,
but with that level of power becomes this unbelievable level of paranoia.
Like those people with those houses sitting on the ridge looking down into the
rose bowl,
there's a fear.
Like we sit there looking up at it,
go look at,
they got the fucking world.
There was a fear of when you attain that level of wealth,
of losing all of it,
and you've,
you begin on this,
this quest to quiet your mind,
you want,
you want to get a level of wealth and controlling your life that you are
guaranteed that it will never go away in your lifetime or your kids' lifetime or
your kids' kids.
So basically everybody that you know and love will be okay and you will be okay.
You get into that psychotic fucking mindset and uh,
you give those kinds of people this level of fucking technology and you're going
to have a problem.
I think that's unbelievable.
But that this shit is,
so they have this,
this website here,
uh,
the eff electronic frontier foundation that is trying to fight.
Yeah.
These things being put into,
into the,
the tech,
you know,
the cameras,
the cell phones and all that shit.
Like the fact that there's a tracking device in your cell phone.
Like how come we didn't get to vote on that?
How come we don't get to vote on that type of stuff?
I don't want people knowing where the fuck I am at all.
God Damn Times.
Okay.
And I don't need you to show me,
Oh,
we caught this fucking child molester with that.
So because of that,
now everybody has to be like,
give me a fucking break.
They always have like,
you know that there's,
you know,
a handful of good examples for that level of fucking control.
And then there's a zillion bad ones.
So I am 100% against the shit.
And,
um,
there's always been evil people in the fucking world.
There's always going to be evil fucking people in the world.
And when you get,
when you have this kind of technology that you're going to,
you're going to stop.
They're going to stop small evil,
like individual,
you know,
a fucking a serial rapist,
which you definitely want to stop.
All right?
But the price we're going to pay is you're going to allow a Stalin or a Hitler
Pol Pot,
whoever the fuck you want it,
you're going to la with that level of technology up to someone like that could
get in power and,
and run the fucking world.
So,
you know,
I dunno
totally 100% believe that you could roll all your fucking eyes all you want.
I,
I honestly believe that.
And I also believe that the reason why there's so many of us right now and that
the people at the top are not fucking concerned about it
is because we're all expendable.
And when the waters rise up,
the temperatures goes up and everything,
they're not going to be the ones who are drowning.
You can guarantee that the user in our taxpayer money to build some sort of
something to make sure that they're okay.
And I think that their bailout plan because they know they can't stop people
from fucking,
because it feels too God damn good and Dixon pussies are readily available to
anyone.
It's like air,
you know?
Okay.
So I think what they're going to gradually do is phase us out with robots and
automated shit,
which is why I refuse to use it now.
How fucking crazy do I sound right now?
Has there been anything funny in the last fucking
five?
This is shit that I truly believe.
Okay.
You know corporations own like the DNA of a grizzly bear.
That's why they don't give a fuck that they're cutting down its habitat.
They're like,
I will fucking grow another one in a petri dish.
We're trying to take over everything and then wipe out.
I think they're going to try to wipe out the poor and the middle class keep a
couple of us,
like a small handful of us.
You know,
the way that pandas are only in like a zoos at this point or some shit.
I don't know what made it pick the wrong fucking animal,
but that,
that that's,
that's the direction I think it's going.
All right.
This your first crazy rant,
which was based mainly at gut feelings and a couple of emails,
but,
um,
I truly believe that.
Wow.
John,
do you get a bad beat U of o.